[Música]
parís vuelve al uso obligatorio de
mascarillas en el espacio público a
medida que los nuevos casos diarios ya
superan la barrera de los 200.000 el
gobierno francés también cerró el paso
por el eurotúnel a los británicos no
residentes en el país
china impuso sanciones a cinco
ciudadanos estadounidenses en respuesta
a una medida similar a anunciada por
washington el lunes contra funcionarios
chinos en la región de hong kong beijing
el rechaza lo que considera una
injerencia en sus asuntos internos
y comenzaron los homenajes de velación
del fallecido nobel de paso de
sudafricano desmond tutu sus restos
mortales permanecerán en la catedral de
san jorge hasta su funeral e
incineración el próximo primero de enero
bienvenidos a este resumen informativo
en francés 24 los saluda daniel hablando
desde este viernes será de nuevo
obligatorio el uso de mascarillas en las
calles de parís debido al aumento de
infecciones por kobe de 19 la decisión
se produce después de que el primer
ministro fan francés de jean castex
anunciara al principio de esta semana
restricciones a las reuniones y
recomendaciones sobre trabajo a
distancia el país viene registrando
récords consecutivos de contagios que
superan los 200.000 diarios por otro
lado los británicos que no sean
residentes de francia no podrán usar el
eurotúnel bajo el canal de la mancha
para transitar por carretera hacia
territorio galo dado que ya no forman
parte de la unión europea y en los 27
fortalecen sus medidas contra el virus
por eso vamos a reino unido con nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido para conocer
las reacciones del lado británico louis
a muy buenas tardes como recibe esta
noticia del gobierno de boris johnson
pues hasta el momento no se conoce una
reacción oficial por parte del gobierno
británico pero lo cierto es que ha sido
un día de mucha confusión de tensión
para los viajeros finalmente francia
esta noche anunciado que permitirá que
los ciudadanos británicos
viajen por su territorio por vía
terrestre si van a su casa en un país de
la unión europea durante las fiestas
pero como sabemos han sido más de 24
horas de mucha atención de confusión
sobre todo de los británicos que viven
en países europeos y quieren pasar las
fiestas de nuevo año aquí en el reino
unido- y tienden a viajar por ser una de
las rutas más fáciles por francia el
eurotúnel había dicho anoche que por ser
el reino unido- ya un tercer país
después del break si no se permitía
entonces ese tránsito pero esto ya se ha
aclarado si se permitirá durante las
fiestas esta decisión de francia se
perfilaba como una nueva atención en
esta ya larga lista creciente de
fricciones entre boris johnson y emanuel
macro luisa y que tanto afectará a este
bloqueo pues la vida normal de los
ciudadanos en el reino unido
desde el 18 de diciembre francia no
permite el ingreso de ciudadanos
británicos a su territorio salvo medidas
excepcionales esto por la explosión de
casos de la variante omicron en este
país pero como ya lo mencionaba francia
también está registrando casos récords
en su territorio ahora que ya se ha
aclarado que los ciudanos británicos
podrán transitar por las fiestas en esta
temporada por el territorio británico
por vía terrestre la pregunta que queda
ahora por resolver es esta es una medida
temporal o excepcional es un panorama
bien complejo para los ciudadanos
británicos que residen en otros países
de la unión europea porque la vía más
sencilla para ingresar al reino unido-
por supuesto es a través de francia y si
se mantiene esta medida a lo largo de
2022 será una razón más de complicación
para todos los viajeros pero también
traerá tensiones políticas nuevas entre
francia y el reino unido- pues muchas
gracias a luisa desde el reino unido-
ahora cambiamos de información porque la
organización mundial de la salud
todo en las últimas 24 horas algo más de
un millón
351 mil casos de kobe de 19 en todo el
planeta una cifra diaria que pulveriza a
todos los registros hasta ahora tomados
durante dos años de pandemia y que
también refleja la compleja situación
sanitaria a nivel global detrás de estas
cifras está la combinación de la
incidencia de las variantes delta iv o
microonda el virus nos amplía álvaro
cortez
más de un millón 351 mil casos de kobe
19 en un día en el planeta esta cifra
arrojada por la oms nunca antes se había
registrado en dos años de pandemia y
refleja la alta incidencia que está
teniendo o micro una variante mucho más
contagiosa que las registradas
anteriormente sin que haya mermado la
temida delta delta en omicron artwin
trets delta yo me con son amenazas
gemelas que están elevando los casos a
cifra récord widget game lo que
nuevamente está provocando picos en las
hospitalizaciones y muertes antes
a miley cansan estoy muy preocupado de
que omicron al ser más transmisible
circula el mismo tiempo que delta ya que
está provocando un tsunami de casos
sliding de tsunami of case es esta ola
de contagios está afectando a todo el
mundo por igual en américa latina países
como argentina y bolivia han registrado
récords de casos en eeuu la realidad no
es mucho mejor ya que se estima que
omicron es la variante dominante pero el
continente más afectado es europa donde
omicron ha emergido poco antes de las
navidades sin embargo aunque los casos
están muy elevados las restricciones han
vuelto de forma parcial y muchos no
creen que la situación sea peor que en
esto no tiene nada que ver con el año
pasado hace un sequía de casas
sabemos que hay casos que están
aumentando pero no nos damos cuenta
tratamos de vivir con normalidad claro
respetando las normas de salud pero esto
no nos impedirá vivir normalmente
esto se puede entender porque omicron a
pesar de ser extremadamente contagiosa
incluso entre gente vacunada posee una
tasa de mortalidad y hospitalización
menor que las otras variantes
hablamos ahora de china que impuso
sanciones a cinco ciudadanos
estadounidenses una acción que responde
a la misma medida tomada por washington
el pasado lunes cuando confirmó
sanciones a cinco funcionarios de la
oficina del enlace de gobierno popular
central en la región de hong kong
comentó en su mail una vez más instamos
a eeuu a que levante todas las sanciones
contra los ciudadanos chinos y deje de
entrometerse en los asuntos de hong kong
y de interferir en la política interna
de china china continuará tomando todas
las medidas necesarias para defender los
intereses nacionales de acuerdo con la
ley li fuyan seguimos en la región dos
ex editores arrestados en hong kong
durante una redada policial contra el
medio están detenidos fueron acusados de
delitos relacionados con sedición a
aproximadamente 200 policías allanaron
la oficina de la publicación en línea
congelaron sus activos y arrestaron a
siete personas está en términos o
funciona desde 2014 como un medio
crítico de la china continental luego
triunfo si el gobierno de los eeuu no le
teme a la verdad y tiene confianza
porque busca la extradición
porque nos trató de ayudar es no dude en
como un denunciante eeuu debería
abandonar la hipocresía y la doble moral
y dejar de interferir en los asuntos
internos de china en nombre de la
libertad twitter snowdon y nueva jornada
de manifestaciones contra la cúpula
militar en sudán según el comité central
de médicos durante enfrentamientos entre
las fuerzas de seguridad y los
manifestantes al menos tres personas
perdieron la vida miles de ciudadanos
exigen que los militares responsables
del golpe del 25 de octubre no
desempeñen en ningún papel en el
gobierno de transición
y los restos mortales del arzobispo
desmond tutu llegaron la ciudad del cabo
donde se celebran sus últimos homenajes
el ataúdes del premio nobel de la paz y
héroe nacional que luchó por acabar con
el apartheid y llevar la democracia y la
libertad a sudáfrica permanecerá en la
catedral de san jorge hasta su funeral e
incineración el primero de enero
de vuelta a la ciudad del cabo en su
propia catedral el arzobispo desmond
tutu tendrá un último adiós en la misma
edificación religiosa donde lideró su
lucha contra el apartheid abogando por
la libertad la democracia y el amor
entre los sudafricanos
desde su fallecimiento el pasado fin de
semana a los 90 años la nación le ha
rendido tributo
líderes de una docena de religiones se
reunieron en un servicio interreligioso
el miércoles llamando a continuar el
legado de tolerancia del arzobispo tutú
y defendió la justicia e incluso después
de que recibiéramos la libertad ya sea
en el cine o cualquier partido político
cuando siente que se está haciendo mal
se levantó como un verdadero líder y eso
es el verdadero liderazgo
todos desde los residentes hasta el
alcalde de johannesburgo
compartieron su admiración por desmontó
y su viuda
solían compartir un plato de comida con
mi madre
mantu tus solía venir a casa como el
moro con mi madre en realidad no eran
elevados no siempre fueron humildes para
mostrar su amor a la comunidad el kobe
19 ha hecho imposible que las multitudes
se reúnan en ciudad del cabo pero muchos
acabarán a desmond tutu desde cualquier
lugar de sudáfrica
hasta aquí este resumen de noticias pero
hay más para ustedes en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]